le chemin de manouane est une route côte
qui semble mener nulle part pourtant à
90 km au nord de saint-michel-des-saints
on arrive à un poste de contrôle
on a presque l'impression de franchir
une frontière d'entrer dans un autre
monde celui de joyce et jake one
on est parti très jeune j'avais deux ans
quand qu'on est parti de manouane jolie
anne hathaway a vécu une enfance
malheureusement presque classique ici à
cause du surpeuplement dans la réserve
où vivent parfois quinze personnes sous
un même toit
elle déménage à joliette enfin c'est à
l'hôpital que julien ne retrouve un peu
de sa communauté
j'allais me promener dans les étages
pour voir si je tomberai pas sur
quelqu'un de ma communauté
j'allais le voir je j'ai interprété
devenue infirmière et les revenus viva
manouane pour travailler auprès des
siens en dispensaire de la communauté
tout comme sandro et jake one qui est le
premier infirmiers praticiens
spécialisés autochtones au québec
un pack bourse l'ours est le symbole le
parterre de la médecine traditionnelle
un symbole lourde de sens pour l'homme
qui est aussi le cousin de joyce
il sait mieux que quiconque avant de
soigner il faut dissiper la méfiance des
patients c'est qu'ils sont en sécurité
ils sont en sécurité à l'intérieur des
soins comme un crooner dans le
dispensaire offre des services de
première ligne c'est la porte d'entrée
du système pour les attikameks de
manouane pour le reste des traitements
ils doivent se rendre à l'hôpital de
joliette
là où le lien de confiance est brisé
quand qui nous appellent piqué qu'on les
voie puis qu'on leur dit bah écoute le
j'ai fait tout mon possible j'ai fait
l'évaluation je pense que c'est son pied
moi je pense faut peut-être envie il
faut qu'elle consulte à l'urgence puis
des fois c'est comme peine un nombre
tellement je veux pas y aller là c'est
tout un système qu'on veut convoquer
bull pour corriger ce système la
communauté attikamek ne veut plus
attendre les annonces du gouvernement
elle veut d'une solution élaborée par
les premières nations est important si
on peut se donner une voix un image ou à
quelque chose de concret à aux cris de
dresser chaque fois il ya une manière de
travailler avec les communautés
autochtones siby flamand a coordonné une
série de consultations depuis la mort de
la mère de 37 ans il s'apprête à
présenter au gouvernement les
recommandations d
communauté autochtone appelé le principe
de joyce avec le principe de jazz d'une
part on veut que le racisme systémique
soit reconnue ça passe aussi par
l'information du personnel soignant
ils réclament que le principe sont
inclus dans le serment des ordres
professionnels et que les autochtones
puissent recevoir un maximum de soins
dans leur communauté
puis pour assurer l'application du
principe les attikameks propose la
création d'un ombudsman le fait de
m'être nombre d'imans autochtones sur
dans ce principe de joyce service à
reconnaître aussi les juridictions
autochtones de philosophie autochtone et
si la crainte qu'un drame comme celui de
joyce et chaque one se reproduisent et
bien présente voilà pourquoi on souhaite
que le principe de joyce soit implanté
rapidement d'ici la fin de l'année si le
gouvernement le goût refuse les
attikameks n'écarte pas la possibilité
de se tourner vers les tribunaux pour
l'y contraindre
et si valérie gamache radio canada
manoian